hey if you want to get some epic anime
merch that you're not gonna find
anywhere else check out our online store
anime out Broadcom we have esken or
praise the Sun Mele Otis feel the wrath
bond love the pain more esken or more
Mele Otis and other things too so check
us out link in the description what is
up everybody its Anna Mac here for anime
uproar and today I will be breaking down
the very latest events in this story of
the seven deadly sins including the end
finally getting her time to shine
although to be fair it wasn't a lot of
time and the return of Big Daddy
sunshine at his absolute strongest this
current fight really appears to be
entering its climax and the next few
chapters of the manga could be crucial
so let's dive deep into everything
that's happening right now if you
enjoyed the seven deadly sins content on
this channel and you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime abroad
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification Val just the heads of this
video will be dealing with the latest
developments in the seven deadly sins
story and that includes manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the previous chapter it
appeared as if the end could finally get
a moment to shine after spending a
relatively long time in the background
meliodas Bond King s Kannur and Merlin
have all played important roles in at
least some of the most recent fights
Gotha played the critical role of
allowing the sense to enter the souls of
those whom the demon king was possessing
in order to try to get through to them
from the inside and even elizabeth has
directly fought against the demon king
and she has also been healing her
comrades using her goddess powers so
naturally after the previous chapter we
were all excited to see what the end
would be able to do especially now that
the demon king is stronger than he has
ever been the end definitely has
strengths and unique giant clan
abilities but I'll be the first to admit
that I had no idea how the N would be
able to make a difference in this
current battle however naka bouzouki did
have a good plan for the end and this
plan came to fruition during the course
of Chapter three to six it has been
clear to us for a while now that the
demon king has been drawing a lot of his
power from the match
click above which the battle has been
taking place the lake has been allowing
the demon king to constantly replenish
his magic reserves as he has been
fighting against the seven deadly sins
and that has been one of the biggest
reasons why bond-esque and Orrin King
together seem to be incapable of causing
any lasting damage to the demon king so
with all of this in mind the N uses her
unique ability of manipulating the earth
the giant clan ability known as creation
in order to take away the demon king his
key advantage on the battlefield using
creation DeeAnn is able to completely
transform the terrain upon which the
fight is taking place and even though
the demon king completely underestimates
DeeAnn at first with the power of her
drawls dance and the newfound confidence
that she has both in herself and in her
friends the N is able to overpower the
demon king for long enough to lift him
up out of the lake the demon king still
refuses to accept that someone like the
enemy ur giant girl could ever defeat
someone like him but meliodas warns his
father that the N is the type of girl
that will put others ahead of herself no
matter how hard the situation she is
facing might be Mellie Otis is
essentially cautioning the demon King
not to underestimate someone like the N
DN proceeds to call herself the queen of
the Giants because drol had entrusted
the future of the giant's clan to her
and she is determined to make a
difference in this fight because she has
to help protect her dear friends
including of course king after bond
chides him for not being more forward in
this crucial moment King exclaims to the
end and they must not waste any more
time and as soon as the demon king is
defeated he wants the two of them to get
married DN blushes when she hears this
but she doesn't get all gooey and it
doesn't distract her instead this
motivates her to fight even harder and
she continues to use creation to launch
the demon king higher and higher in the
air after he is thrown high enough the n
quickly builds a massive platform above
ground to serve as the new battlefield
between the demon king and the seven
deadly sins now that he is on the
platform the demon king is no longer in
direct contact with the lake which means
that he presumably cannot keep
replenishing his magic as easily as
before all the sins are now assembled
right there on the platform and they are
facing the demon king
confidence they announced the launch of
a new mission defeat the demon king I
mean I feel like this mission has been
going on for like dozens of chapters now
so I wouldn't say the mission is only
being launched now but whatever let's go
with it
the demon king is clearly not happy
about this turn of events but he is
definitely not looking scared or
intimidated either he is ready to make
these insufferable creatures pay for
inconveniencing him in this way just a
side note but at this point the demon
king really does look like a new villain
from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure in this
form he would fit into the Jojo universe
so well he just needs to make more
over-the-top flamboyant movements with
his body and he'll be set moving on Mele
ODIs points out what we already know now
that they are up here on the platform
the demon king has been cut off from the
magic lake and so he can replenish his
magic any longer all seven sins are
ready to face off against the demon king
once and for all and if that was enough
Eskin or casually says that he has to
add one more piece of bad news for the
demon king that just came in and that
piece of news is that it's High Noon
that's right it's High Noon boys and Big
Daddy sunshine is beginning his epic
transformation into the one and that is
how the chapter ends a lot of you guys
in the comments of our seven deadly sins
videos have been saying over and over
again that we have to see esken or in
his the one form again ending this fight
without asking or entering the one would
have been a bit anticlimactic no matter
how great the fight turned out to be
otherwise and I completely agree with
these comments so you can bet that I was
absolutely hyped to see that yes ESCA
noir is going to be entering the one
once more and it's happening right now
it's happening during this crucially
important time in the battle against the
demon king for the next 60 seconds and
in the wonderful world of manga sixty
Seconds could still be like 10 chapters
the sins are going to be at their
absolute strongest and if ever there was
a time to strike at the most powerful
incarnation of the demon king it is now
not to mention that gelda and zelgius
are still fighting to stop the demon
king from the inside so the next few
chapters could spell doom for
demon king and all his hopes and
ambitions in the mortal realm but even
though it isn't looking too good for the
demon king at this point we can't forget
that things aren't really that simple
ESCA nor may appear to be invincible in
his the one form but as we've learned
ESCA Norris human body has been
approaching its limit for a while now
and even though the one will make a
second or stronger in the short term
over exerting himself now could actually
spell disaster for him in the long term
we know what kind of person s Kannur is
and we know that when it comes to
protecting his friends he will ignore
his own well-being and the limits of his
body and this could lead him to getting
severely injured or even dying with that
said my prediction is that teamwork will
be crucial for the rest of this fight
sure we're all extremely hyped to see
the one but even a second or in the one
form will not be enough on his own to
defeat the demon king don't forget that
ESCA nor in the one form could not
defeat the original demon and the
original demon is considerably weaker
than his creator the demon king and his
absolute strongest so well I think that
as Kannur is definitely going to play a
major role in the fight going forward in
order to win the sins we'll all need to
work together maybe even coming up with
a seven deadly sins combo move like they
did in the prisoners of the sky movie on
top of that we also have Elizabeth there
and Zelda's and gelda on the inside and
who knows what other characters might
still show up later and I really do
think that all of them will have to work
together to ultimately defeat the demon
king I don't think just askin or even it
is strongest or even just notice that is
strongest will be enough but who knows
at this point maybe the demon king is
just going to get rekt by hawks mama and
that will be the end of it do let me
know what you guys think are you excited
for the glorious return of the one and
do you think that the fight is now all
but over or are we in for more twists
and turns let me know down in the
comments if you enjoy the seven deadly
sins content on this channel please
leave a like to let me know and if you
have it to be new to anime uproar please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell I want to thank our
visual editor on this video core for
being awesome and for helping us bring
more content to you here on the anime
uproar channel core is one of the
several editors who through their hard
work have allowed us to produce a lot
more content than we used to so please
show core some love and followers you
Tube channel and Twitter both are anime
focused quality web content so be sure
to check them out
I will link both of them down in the
description feel free to also follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest 7 Deadly Sins news
and updates i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime upper patrons
for supporting our work and making our
videos possible a special thank you to
all of our pro hero to your patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius and on hell crews on Epic thank
you to all of our the one tier patrons
the ones who stand above all other clans
including baby ray ace
Ingrid ah Aloha Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun and keelon and finally at the
pinnacle of interdimensional greatness a
tier reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to Regan Harrison and Lord
naksan or disciples of Lord we go
himself if you enjoy our videos and you
think they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon link
in the description even a single dollar
will give you access to our exclusive
patron only discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us bass cowboys
[Music]